alright hey everybody thank you once
again for listening to rhythm with
Griffin I I'm over here at risking
Studios have to put in some place we're
here different studios recording live
and I got with me a special guest mr.
Adam ray everybody hey you think of this
I like this kind of lives to the
audience I know you want that we all
want that no no did you ever practice
that as a kid like oh man I'm on stage
and hear it like did you have echo your
folks are just like do it for yourself
you know let me be me well you can't be
normal and you got a walking stick well
I said this is a wond thank you very
much it was it was given to Brad's
walking stick it's a one from what from
what I love how quickly you pulled it
out of my hand is this like you need a
red belt before you kid pick up somebody
you'll pick up man's wand is that a
Potter wand or no you know what at the
at the Nashville what's the club in
Nashville Denny's zany's one of the
waitresses she heard me talking about
Harry Potter and then she was like you
know I actually make Harry Potter wands
when I was like really she just makes
once and so she brought me that like the
day second day of the shows and I was
like oh that's pretty awesome so you
know whenever I think we do you know
what we do is pretty cool then you go on
and you hear about people that make
wands and you don't know I thought I had
a lot of time on my hands okay so I know
you know I don't know if you watch the
show or not I do you sit all the way
over here okay good yeah so I got you
know I get like a song title alone is
one of the best podcasts which one based
on title alone oh this is one of the
best podcast but also I've been telling
you for you know you're such an about
last night podcast
legend so there's only it was only a
matter of time it's a job then to let
you know quick fat is here I could go
back and listen to it quicker quick fat
episode people still by the way yeah
didn't I tell you I was in Australia no
I was in Australia if somebody came up
to me was like quick fat no I was like
damn that's when I knew that was the
first time I said I need to do a podcast
yeah that's a long laughs that's a long
dish well you know I do theme songs on
the podcast the last episode that I did
it's a solo episode I haven't even
released it yet as of filming this one
right here but like I get so many great
theme songs you know the one with Matt
Wright is so far one of my favorites oh
you like that one I think that was um
oh that's um was that Marty Bru Germann
I think that was Marty you know you know
just you know what just cuz you said
that we're gonna use that theme song for
okay okay the atom ray theme song
episode I don't know what episode this
is but this is we're from with Griffin
and this is once again the great Marty
Bruggeman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
she's got a very it's got almost like a
Kiwis Playhouse commercial break
Corona commercial I know right when you
board the cruise and like you know the
cameras behind you as you walk on the
ship and you see like the whole thing
you see the family swim in you see the
guy that buffeted someone doing karaoke
and you're like and it's like through
the eyes of a kid seeing a cruise ship
for the first time I mean I thought
thought of using when I said I first
heard it I was like I feel like we own
the Lido deck of a carnival yeah yeah
you know we don't know why had we get
records we can keep it you don't have to
keep these on okay it's up to you get
money alright we keep mine in this case
so we can go to the singing I can write
on it
you know we might we might we might go
to the singing but anyways you know as
much as we know each other we yeah we
don't know each other you know as much
as we talk about stuff yeah it's all
experimental this is my second guess
she's not even gonna see my first cast
cuz I messed up I had technical
difficulties I'm gonna release a little
bit of it called a technical
difficulties episode that's in the
neighborhood vodcast no technical
difficulty real low expectations yeah
but um so I know you're originally from
Seattle yeah right so you uh you
actually started doing comedy in Seattle
I did maybe two open mics in Seattle
before I moved here so I consider myself
starting here oh wow I mean wouldn't you
you know like where you really cut your
teeth and I know well I mean I started I
mean I started in LA you know what I
mean yeah and it was um if you did to
open mics in a place and then moved
you wouldn't say I start I mean that's
true it's however you break down did I
start start yeah the first time I did
stand-up was in Seattle right what
started and and you know really hit the
open mics and and chose to make it like
you know a priority like the I here
oh so you can see yourself in an LA
comic or sure yeah right right but you
were doing a lot of stuff like oh [ __ ]
that's oh by the way your impression of
a soda opening is like one of the
original alternatives they had for the
Batman fight sounds
Skiba here's the Joker's
keep up ow now we'll sit up for the
opening of a cherry coke anyways so you
started but I know you were doing a lot
of shows in Seattle cuz I remember you
were like well when I go back now I try
to do a lot but yeah I mean I did
probably you know in like two or three
open mics brought a bunch of friends the
second time I did it I probably bought
brought 20 people and and I ran the
light by like two minutes and the owner
of giggles at the time Terry Taylor yeah
did you ever do it like it was the club
for a while and it was in one University
Village right right next to University
of Washington it's still a great room
they the guy who owns Laughs comedy spot
now bought it and turned it back because
it went from giggles to a strip club
called giggles and then and then back
you know and the reason why they named
it jiggles is because they didn't want
to pay for the sign yes so they just
same type of bombing was happening on
stage just maybe a little funnier
jiggles but um see you never did because
I was doing John Fox rooms yeah I was
doing uh what was the new ground
underground that's and that is a really
great room it's just like it needs to be
you know refurbished a little but um are
you talking about like the original one
or the one a video the one I've done the
one I've done the one that they had
before this one is there an how many I
have a basis in the same is moved across
the street oh he probably did the
original I did the original what how was
that oh it was I don't know I mean that
guy's like he just I heard you meet Eric
Myers sleep in the Eric Myers recovering
alcoholic who you know oh he's got he
slept in like the freezer with the
alcohol yeah yeah
in the yeah in the alcohol closet what
do you must I didn't get my hotel room
Eric didn't wanna fly took us train up
there so took a train you know 37 hours
from LA to Seattle and then it's like
he's like a normal hotel room where you
can sleep with the booze
[ __ ] what do you think happens he's
like scare the dark and thinks goat like
what do you mean you can sleep with the
booze yeah so he falls off the wagon
obviously which of the next day just
shit-faced like half the Jack dangle
is gone like oh my god what kind of that
that's that's actually like hurts my
heart - yeah like you're gonna put a
blind guy in a shark tank yeah well I
mean you got I don't know if I think if
you put a blind guy anywhere like like
it's a shark let's try to think of one
of the most scariest so nobody's formed
you wake up in this example it'd be like
you put the blind guy with the knives
there's a nice way how rich are you
that's my idea of money you've got so
many knives you need a room dedicated
for them well that is like that's just
that's nonsense much oh yeah did I want
nonsense well many will get there I
don't know Kelly well no I don't I don't
I'm talking about this what you don't
know what to do with being wealthy yeah
okay and then in this society people
have a wrong idea of money like if you
have a million dollars in the bank you
don't got a nice room yeah you know cuz
you're gonna you're actually gonna have
to keep your job to like because you
know that's just a little nest but like
you know it's two million dollars a lot
of money yeah I feel like okay but where
you living yeah you're right I mean I
don't got a mansion oh no forty fifty
million have a mansion okay okay let's
say you have 50 million dollars in the
bank because what your lifestyle say on
this like I'm saying you're starting
with 50 million okay what do you do
how much is your mansion probably a 10
million dollar mansion so you paying the
10 upfront for it yeah okay so you paint
it in yeah so plus the tax and all that
all right now the upkeep of a 10 million
dollar mansion it's not bad you know
there's a just notice it's really gonna
be bad you're talking about dark I got
an indoor garden you got indoor pool
yeah he got all that case your staff I
got Wolfgang Puck cooking for me every
Tuesday we Friday and Sunday but only
thirty million dollars left yeah that's
a couple mil for Wolfgang okay so you're
talking about but per year what a meal
you just one meal when he comes in it's
not there for like five six hours I know
but I just want him to open the jar of
pickles cuz I'm like it looks better
with you but a bit but how much do you
think the maintenance for a ten million
dollar mansion is a month do you think
that's twenty thousand a month that yeah
if you think it's thirty thousand a
month
I'm just trying to point out that this
is what happens to people this is why
people lose money that's why people with
the lottery lose money because this is
how we think we figured ollars that's a
lot of money but not gonna spend over
because I'm not gonna be able to spent I
won't be able to outlive that money you
might be able to yeah if Mike Tyson had
a hundred fifty and he lost it cuz he
had Tigers at parties and stuff like
that I'm just saying what do you think
I'm just saying like what's dumb money
I'm at one point of is is it a hundred
million dollars you know I get a hundred
million dollars you have you ten million
dollar mansion you know you put five
million dollars in a trust fund that
like that that the interest runs your
household yeah I mean you know now
you're talking I mean I definitely would
once but even by the way not to
interrupt but ten million dollars house
you still might not have a knife room
wanna because dude houses where you live
in you live in California let's say
we're living in LA wow yeah I was
thinking of like you know Boise Idaho
[Laughter]
Boise and Boise that's why she told got
a farm in Ohio right I get it
I'm watched up like that so he's if I
own so much land with right I mean I
don't know you have to imagine I love
going to those like websites it's like
you know richest people in America are
like what I get no like I love going to
those lists where it's like top 50 um
estates are most expensive and that Tom
Cruise had this you know a lot of people
live in Montana
yeah the national Sandra's got a place
in Jacksonville oh man Tom Cruise had
this place everything - they like there
was it looked like there was no one for
a thousand miles and oh my god just look
like that and then he did it for this
view of like the sunset just for the
view yeah I was like damn he yeah I
won't peek out I had down money Oh Tom
Cruise is probably secretly one of the
richest guys ever
maybe you're something with sight but
you never hear him on those lists you
know
dude I will smith here about what though
if you're if you're on the list
you don't got dumb money okay if people
don't pay to get on the list I'm saying
to people that got the real money
they're never on lifestyles of the rich
and famous and I get like like Warren
Buffett's not gonna be on cribs and that
is why I can't sleep at night it would
just be the servants quarters yeah and
you would be like what yeah you're
serving to living like this dude there
is a thirty billion dollars there's a
lost episode of cribs that I I want to
see so bad that just features like
Warren Buffett and Celine Dion you know
and Richard Branson by the way I'm
telling you Celine Dion does not go in
that category she's got so much money
for sure she does not Billy she does he
have a billion dollars but she's got
over a hundred mil for sure okay that's
not dumb money we have a different idea
what dumb money yeah I like you know
what I like about you you're a simple
man yeah I am you're gonna mean I'm and
you're looking at me like I'm crazy how
much money dollars I'm monies like what
like like a couple bill you yeah you
have to be even 300 million do these
baseball players what's he like yeah I
kraut 430 or whatever million check it
out he don't have it all at once yeah so
he has 30 which is actually 15 yeah
which agents manager fees you know he's
losing 40 50 percent of that so at the
end of it right in 13 years he still
he's gonna have and he's probably spent
money so at the end of the 13 years he
thought he might only have like you know
a hundred million dollars wrong like he
had a 90 mil before he even played a
basketball game probably got a lot of
them he'll probably be the one of the
one another billionaire athlete but I'm
just saying man like just like dumb
money is not talk about dumb money like
I saw one of these shows and they had
these like they said the richest houses
in the world you know and it was like it
was like it was like a secret thing
where like he you know they were like
they couldn't show you where they are
right it's just like you know you'd they
had to they were showing you they do
they had to blindfold people was on Long
Island I don't know what it would but
this one house it was a hundred and
fifty million dollars yeah okay for the
house yeah this is what I'm trying to
tell you about dumb money okay
150-foot a house
and the maintenance for the house per
month you had this marble expensive
[ __ ] you had to clean weekly or it
would go bad
so he's it was security to get a marble
staff so it's like what's your marble
budget so when you have a when you have
like like a $50,000 a month budget yeah
to run your house
that's dumb money man yeah and check it
out the [ __ ] that owned it don't
even stay there yeah I know people like
that just own properties and they're
never there
imagine owning a hundred fifty million
dollar property that it cost so much
money per month and you don't you're
barely there that's what I'm saying
forget to even have that place you like
go to visit bets here and you're like
we're gonna stay oh [ __ ] how about our
house you know I'm always tripping when
I keep kidnapped I don't think about
tripping with Griffin
no but I think like you know I in my own
place I always wonder like man where's
that jacket did I leave it in a clock
imagine like you know I want a mansion
yeah nothing is just in your mansion you
lost your jacket in one of your mansions
Wow
do you have a staff that just you know
jackets down where did I put this
brother
just like you know catalogs everything
you put down would I want to find it
truman show your day they just journal
everything I want to find it Butler yeah
he's just like oh it's like I do with
glasses and yeah like he's in a row he's
in a room that has like only he goes in
there the thing I was directing like the
Grammys he's sitting in a room with all
the cameras she's following you camera
seven yeah come before yeah camera five
this is the end of the day you get to
watch it wait wait yes too much I asked
you to watch the highlight reel from
your day you're firing editors all the
time Skye cutaway too quick I'm like can
you explain this shot right when I was
getting to the good part of that
sandwich you cut away I wanted to go
closer you zoom in on my face for the
plate what my point I'm trying to tell
you is you can't do this
yeah with five million dollars you can't
you know you don't have it you know you
can't have a
follow you around staff so we got five
million dollars that's what I'm gonna
win the lottery or um or get you know a
show that just is internationally that's
how you do it right
international movie money I don't know
how do you got at this point I don't
know anymore
yeah what would you if you won the
lottery it's 500 million you quit
stand-up I don't know man I mean are you
open up you open up Ray's stand-up clubs
like you don't to like 10 of them from
every club yeah [ __ ] I don't know maybe
I'd um you know I maybe I'd open a
podcast studio right next to Joe Rogan's
and just try to go toe-to-toe with them
I know it's like don't you feel like
you're slumming I like being here every
time he gets like a crossbow like I get
like a I get like a live Buffalo that I
can shoot the crossbow if I had five
hundred million I would buy the Laugh
Factory
and the comedy store yeah I would just
buy it I love them both to be like I
want this and do what give me a price
yeah I won't tell them you know and they
would tell to you if you said give me a
price so yeah if I sit boys would they
sell it for fifty million dollars the
rights everything Wow you don't mean the
fight if I came to the shore family
here's 50 million dollars I wanted OSH
yeah like a Brinks truck is behind just
there with me that Jamie would I don't
think he would you know I think you
would up no not so he would stages it
would think that you know it's like once
you've built that up like how do you let
that go like I know you know it's it's
you know I would want to think that
there's a price for anything but that's
I mean I don't you know I have a tough
time just even given away you know the
thing is the shoes the thing is if
somebody comes to you and says excuse me
if somebody comes he was like yo I'm
gonna give you five hundred dollars for
that hat now your first thought might be
I wonder why he's paying $500 yes and
then you're like I gotta go let me go
see if I can make fire without you know
me that I go I could clearly get another
one of these hats but this one fits my
head good
and it is a little dirty I should get a
new one but maybe maybe this is a sign
or something of that like maybe but you
what could I do with that 500 bucks what
I'm saying is like is that all going
through your head fast would you just
give it up would you just like be like
okay here's a hat I probably say no
because I'd be suspicious well yeah yeah
this is what I'm saying though 500 feels
like a thousand maybe I would okay so
you have a price there so you're like
your price okay let's say like that hat
like like ken griffey jr. I'll sell my
body to science for 1500 some like
calves are so big yeah you into the cap
thing you thought you were gonna come
out like daredevil and you came this is
that was emphatic I used to do this
stair stepper when I was first started
like going to the gym in like in seventh
grade why what visit my dad in Arizona
and all my folks put and he was living
down there and my sister and I just went
did this like country club well he
worked all day we we got passes where
this Country Club and we befriended like
the people the Desa is let's go there
for free and how we just like we should
be there all day so if I click
basketball and swim mrs. gonna play
tennis
she fart around and just like you know
talk to guys and and I just like do the
Machine but I like did this stair-step
but for like sometimes like two hours at
a time
really oh yeah I'm surprised I don't
know why I tore my cat before the
celebrity all-star game you know that I
tore it do too and still play oh you
played I had nine points seemed brand
out there is just [ __ ] hilarious yes
yeah if you scored I told him the whole
place will explode this place would have
went yeah and I was like you would have
you know that I mean when he stole the
tip and then even when he went through
my legs one point I was like he almost
made that one when he stole the tipping
at the fast break fast break is just not
his forte well first of all take the
word fast
the break to the hoop yeah but yeah you
guys look so happy like I was looking at
your as Instagram yes just one of those
moments that you think look at what we
do
yeah and then we get to do this it's
like every person you meet you're like
oh yeah dude what dude seeing I mean
yeah it was definitely I only was a
bucket list
just a cuz you know I joke about I
didn't want to play in the NBA and I'll
it's my favorite sport so just to be you
wanted to play in the NBA
yeah it's the longest time was there a
thought in your head that just expect it
sixth grade six crazy thought you can
make it he cannot say this when I was
quick that I was the tallest kid okay so
nobody could doubt you can explain quick
fat click fat basically is a term that I
came up with that explains why every 10
20 40 five years there comes along a
fatty that just defies the laws of
gravity I was just like one of those
kung-fu guys it's like the fat kung fu
at all yeah it's real quick like um what
was it in Street Fighter naughty Honda
well he was pretty hot or I get what
you're saying it yeah so um but I was
fast as the skinny kids I just you know
I could say Mike this smell like you
know fruit snacks and pop-tarts when I
sweat but I I was the tallest kid so you
couldn't eat me up in the post
I shot threes all day every day so I
because I like love Reggie Miller and
Larry Bird so I had a I could shoot the
three
I would always practice post moves cuz I
love how it came so I was like this tall
kid that you couldn't be up they could
shoot the three and again was fast so I
was like I wouldn't dominate and I think
I told you this once we were playing
this team in a championship at this
tournament and one of the dads were him
run down court after I hit this skyhook
to put us up like by four with like
eight seconds left I'm running down
court and I just hear him from the other
side just go my spike yeah I was like I
think he's talking about me but but I am
killing him but I was just so dominant
and that and his team was so heavily
favored and because they've been
crushing everybody in the tournament and
we won and I was like and also the way
you know just like anything the way like
now to with sets and you know the way I
mean [ __ ] on on down up here you know
you would tell me that Jim Carrey talked
to you it's like you know after a while
when people the way people were spawned
you like alright what I'm doing is like
it's hitting on many different cylinders
and so I was like oh I think I'm like
I'm having fun I'm seeing what I'm doing
on the court but the boy people are like
talking me about it I'm like I think
like and then on sudden you know you get
older and you just kind of plateau out
of it it's so 8 and a half but what
happens is it like you know everybody's
good you you you realize how you're not
good at all in comparison to yes you
know me I like play basketball
I was late they're getting I mean played
till like my sophomore year in high
school
oh [ __ ] and only because I was tall yeah
and then I had this thing like if you
tell me I can't do something I'm gonna
do it yeah you know one you know so I
was like then that the varsity coach was
like eh you suck you know that kind of
thing and I was like yeah I went to with
the big main camp that's the first time
I learned that I wasn't tall there's a
camp for big man it was called big man
camp so I listened to it I said ma I
gotta go to big man camp you know so she
was like okay I'm gonna gets me out of a
house for a week or whatever it was
right so I went to big man source
yeah cancer Savin Mara knows what she
was doing yeah
so I went to big man camp and that's
when I like I said I realized I'm not
tall like at 6-3 I thought I was talking
my high school's wanted tall this guy's
get out to a small high school yeah but
you know you get it and it's like six
ten seven foot everybody's I was so
little man and I was like oh [ __ ] this
is real I had to dribble the show like
bring the ball little man I was like I
was crazy yeah but I learned some skills
I came back I was all league you know I
mean were you ready yeah that's why you
love the NBA yeah yes I love the NBA I
don't love the highest level of anything
yeah you know I'm not I'm not a huge
college basketball fan right you the
tournament comes around and something
happens they play harder did you watch
the tournament this of course yeah I
mean there's just more at stake a lot of
these guys are playing for the draft
status you know whatever they're playing
for um don't like it I don't like
wouldn't watch like you know like sorry
basketball I don't watch the WNBA you
know I've seen this step down yeah yeah
yeah at the highest level of I don't
even like college football yeah so what
does that translate for like movies you
like Indies you just want those big
blockbusters no oh no because sometimes
a nd you know it's like in the
tournament yeah I mean like ever since
Sunday it's just a tournament the stakes
are high like that Indy might be because
I've been in a few Indies there I'm like
hey you should watch this yeah yeah yeah
no but no this is different cuz I don't
miss that we like I'm not all
blockbusters right you know I love these
Marvel movies but yeah you know isn't it
crazy to the kids today that's all
they're gonna think yeah this is all
movies are yes you know there's no like
there's no for us there was there's no
Bruce Willis right now no the rock is
the closest thing to like what we yeah
they're like that guy in Dumbo so good
we're like oh you mean beetlejuice yeah
you mean the penguin yeah man yeah I
show my nieces beetlejuice the 29 year
old girls and I was like and you start
showing you guys some classics and like
love your nieces yeah so much they love
beetlejuice yeah and that made me so
happy they were like that movie was so
great there's a lot of great movies that
the kids are never gonna see yeah cuz
they're gonna think like this Marvel
[ __ ] has been going on for like over 10
years now yeah so that means if you were
like 8 years old
you're now 18 and all of your life
you're impressionable time of your life
it was all superhero movies and
everything yeah
and you know this better than me how
many more characters and stories are
there to they can keep going forever if
they wanted to I managed to collect
comics I've clicked I used to collect
Marvel Comics I love the spider-man and
Marvel team-up those were my favorites
really yeah I had like some Ninja Turtle
ones and then was a ninja turtle guy I
mean yeah I know dude is you know what
just the way you said that
I'm ninja turtle guy like we don't say
that about our fear is that like you
people yeah you know I worked at
Universal there was in the break room
the character break room they were
almost everybody I was always full so
out of the loop because I'd be sitting
there I'm [ __ ] full Wolverine garb
and I'm sit around the other care
and they would all be comparing comics
and one guy came in he was the number
one Beale juice because you know there
were ranked like when I got hired as
Wolverine I was third string Wolverine
what wait a minute what wait a [ __ ]
minute there was a class that he is yeah
tear nerd tears well those those only
were shed when they found out that I
didn't know what Wolverines favorite
food was oh no these kids wouldn't nerd
out and ask me populous and I would make
up facts and then how you and one kid
definitely one time was just like that's
not right and I was like listen here
[ __ ] I'm just trying to get
through the day yeah I got some open
mikes tonight all right area but yeah
there was uh the the Wolverine above me
where the motorcycle came in in a
Wolverine t-shirt and I was like hey
dude we know you're the guy number one
Wolverine yes oh Jesus and but number
one who was his real hair that's when
you you know how when you don't need a
wig they asked what you're like number
one on the call she I have will Vereen
but he walks to with like this like you
know he would walk yeah yeah did some of
them took it real seriously that's why
when when when Disney bought Marvel and
took the characters out of the park I
remember uh you know the guy who'd been
spider-man there was that for like 15
years right
I was livelihood and we're sitting there
and he looked to me I'm just like
alright [ __ ] like I'm gonna do the New
York cop now think I'm gonna do the fake
cop that walks around you know Universal
and and and so we sit there Zack did you
hear what happened I was like yeah you
got your life back right and you're like
how dare you dude
how dare you spider-man spider-man just
done I'm like yeah man I mean what you
always tell him I go back to school and
[ __ ] like this is look this is like a
blessing in disguise like we really
gonna be spider-man until you were 60
and he was like and using great shape so
he was like you know I put up in yeah at
least 40 that's terrible yeah but the
new comics thing I mean they were just
people were obsessed I always felt so
out of the loop right but I was gonna
say yeah that's equivalent to people
that are into fantasy football yeah like
if you cuz me and my friends that we've
been in a fantasy football league for a
little it's going on 20 years wow that's
unbelievable we're up to almost at 20 I
think we're I think we actually hit 20
years already that we've been in a
league together so I know when we get
together an outsider hearing us talk we
must sound like idiots yeah you know cuz
you know cuz we're talking like that's
my guy
yeah we talk about it so I get like
whatever your group is when you nerd out
with your group that's a great thing and
I can't stand that person that comes in
it's like you know this isn't real
yeah don't shatter my [ __ ] try no
dude there's not [ __ ] in the day oh
my god yeah people want to they want to
go out of the way to squash joy yeah
they're the fantasy football thing that
that is uh people get so into that I
have done it once and I you don't do
friend to see at all I didn't do it this
year
oh wow especially if we lose our
quarterback you know what this is the
thing though man these guys that I've
been doing this with we only hang out
once a year and it's when we go to the
dinner for and this is the best defense
right and it's like big we talk [ __ ] and
we're like I'm looking at that and it is
key do you leave that dinner going why
don't we hang out more and always make
senator paul waste yeah always it feels
good in the moment and you probably mean
it the moment mean it did them up but
like it's a lot some of them are real
like close friends but it's like as a
collective group we don't necessarily
hang out but like one of them like they
all have like half of them have kids
yeah tougher they're talking about like
their kids are going to high school it's
craziness cuz you know we've known each
other for so long do they have kids that
are now going to high school playing
basketball it's like you've got so you
get those updates yearly that's crazy
right so when we catch up it's like wow
dude and we're always fighting about the
rules in the league I'm the commissioner
in London the Commissioner of the league
for like over 20 years that's awesome
handling the money and all that you know
no no these are just dudes that I just
known from back in my you know more
people normal people you're a guy you
still doing that yeah you're like the
comedian's are they regular people first
of all and I'm last a real feat it is
it's a real thing specially in this day
and age of how sensitive people are and
I also mean regular and normal people by
you know you chose a you know and not
that like like my buddy who's crushing
it with his engineering life that's not
a regular job that's what he's doing
very well fantastic
no but but if he's around engineers yeah
there's a certain like you know there's
no there's a routine
you believe they thought this was cobalt
whatever sex abilities are different
sensibilities I think it took a break
like there's more regular sense of
humours than not right right there's a
higher percentage of people that they
just you know like where was that just
like observing people always them at the
airport and there's a group of gals were
getting ready to go to Vegas and a gal
yeah you know like when he's nineteen
twenties who are you the gals are you
baby man you know my mom's friend from
Temple a little bit too much yeah from
the they were uh they were just you know
chumming it up about going to Vegas but
the things who were joking about like I
could not and obviously like there's
probably a gender you know barrier there
that I'm not relating to but like they
were just laughing about [ __ ] that was
so like one of them she was like then
she thought she she could just get away
with bringing this much stuff unless she
had a small bag of said what up and they
all just wouldn't die in laughing you
know what you know what this reminds me
of is that as comics the time you had an
orgy with a bunch of gals it just
reminds me that we're actually not that
different from everyone else but we like
to think we're different comics
yeah comics but that's just what you
said it's just our sensibility when
we're with comics there's a certain way
because I because then you know I don't
know if you do this but if I listen to
stuff like that sometimes I'll end up
tagging their stories from afar like I'm
thinking of like if I was in that circle
or if I hear them say something it's
just the same way you do it if you see a
commercial or movie or you're writing a
bit like you hear something to trigger
something and you kind of like somebody
said something I was like oh I would
have said that if I was Jill you know
come back with that retort I almost want
to go be like whispering hey you wanna
make this you want to stand out in this
circle you want to get upgrade to first
class on that flight and they're looking
at you like all right get out of here
your friend to let you sleep in the bed
and she'll take the couch if you say
this no yeah but I would yeah I'm
realizing that that every group has
their own sensibility has their own
weirdness for sure you know I definitely
have friends so that I just can't kick
it with when I go back home now because
I'm like you're making me do all the
heavy lifting when we hang
oh really yeah you're the funniest guy
in your group no I mean like that's why
I like to hang out with like my friends
that make me laugh all right yeah but I
find
when we the misconception about comics
is that they think we're sitting around
cracking jokes all the time yeah we're
actually super serious like to the point
of like like it's like annoyingly
serious yeah yeah you know it's like you
want to go lighten up bro what the
[ __ ] wrong with you
I know that's why we do podcast this is
like comics love doing pocket yeah cuz
we're up here just being like you know
you know dude in the world and this is
what's wrong with America you know we're
just doing it in a way that makes you
laugh you know no meathead like we're
actually very serious yeah yeah I kissed
the dude that's always that's the guy
nobody wants to be around well it's just
always locked in all gods yeah there's
only one person I don't mind being on
all the time
it's Bryan Callen yeah well because yeah
it's something about his personality
that he could be on like and you're like
well I'm okay with yeah yeah it's
affable yeah but there's some people
there like there's also there's still
some like I'm walking away that's a
special episode a very special riffin
with Griffin beefing with Griffin V
Griffin beef sounds like something you
can get a Ralph's I like beefing with
Griffin but beefing with Griffin it's
not what you think it is
sure well its name in the podcast I'm
talking about the item that sort of a
store Griffin beef perfect I like that
nobody thing would be actually going to
get be yeah yeah I probably do that
you're so positive I'm not positive
you are no no people don't like people
don't like a bowl maybe that's the word
even though I don't make myself
approachable all the time those people
you know you do that [ __ ] yeah you get
to know me I'm in but because there's
too many people that are too familiar
yeah walking around the Comedy Store
took me a while to get a smile out of
you when I walked up to a club yeah I
just cuz I didn't know you yeah but I
appreciate that and that's also that's
the way to do it
you're right these people like edit you
for running the light at that uh a
[ __ ] festival we went to in what was
that
it was one of the Dakotas wasn't it no
it was it was in Bismarck all right on
our ticket it said so where's that I
think it's South Dakota Dakota yeah yeah
this guy supposed to do $25 Fargo
yeah we're 52 minutes into the set I
went first didn't I yeah it was you then
then I don't hunter yeah but anyways
because we meet so many people as we
roam around these clubs and there's a
lot of people trying to do it and it's
just like I just always sometimes have
time for that like how do you do it
energy I don't got time for you there's
also a lot of force I think when you're
starting out you want to be I think like
when I see a lot of young comics like
approaching with a lot of just like hey
what up and a lot of touching and clubs
and a hug and you're like you know we
but you know what that is to me is they
want to they want to skip steps yes then
one skip steps they want to they want
that familiarity and comfort level that
comes with time and experience and and
you have to put in your your hours on
that and but but I see it too a lot of
people that are just because the store
is now becoming such a welcomed hang
obviously there's more security and more
people kind of you know you know
checking in to make sure everyone that's
there is there but it's still very comic
friendly so it's like yeah it's the only
one that's really like that and it's got
as much you know the prestige and the
room for hang so when there's so many
comics I'll see new people every week
and I'm like I've never seen this person
but they'll come up to me like what am i
right give me the thing I'm like what up
man I'm like oh this guy's a young comic
uh but he's just the culture of the
store and the looseness makes everyone
just be like [ __ ] we're all buddies
cuz we're all here but you know there is
like an underbelly of the comedy store
they're sexy levels there's tears at the
Comedy Store like like like you know
there's this shows going on that I
wouldn't I don't know about I wouldn't
ever be on or go to but you hear them
talking about it you know there's like
oh I'm gonna do that you know like Oh
what shows that
yeah so that's that's creating more
opportunities for just you know all
walks of life to be there but I mean it
is nice being is great because like
right now they're going through this
like sort of Renaissance at the Comedy
Store or sure like it'll change at some
point oh it always goes herbs and flows
you know I mean have some flows but like
for right now I feel like at the prime
of my like you know comedic what core I
feel like I'm there wondering when all
this stuff is bad it feels good but you
know I don't know you know I mean I
don't know if who knows it you stand up
forever if I can can you imagine
never stop like if you didn't yeah I
could see myself being out of touch I
was talking to a guy whose comic he's 48
in our business and he goes he was I if
I had the option he goes I at this point
he goes because he's doing a bunch of
writing gigs he goes oh would I like to
make the same amount of money if not a
little more and drive to Burbank instead
of get on a plane he's like for sure I
want to do that you know cuz I was
asking him like cowboy yeah how you
feeling at this spot you know and well I
just know like I'm I wish I was I wish
the road was better yeah I do I wish it
was better like I I don't have the same
eagerness it's like today any time I
don't have to travel like traveling to
work I'm gonna Miami tonight now I'm
going to DC tomorrow let's take care of
some business right now I show you so
you got stuff going on yeah like but
what do you got going on um see I got
the second season of Shira coming out on
Netflix April 26 oh that's great yeah
I'm the voice of her talking horse
sidekick Swift wind oh wow and then my
album is coming out April 26th problem
drop it
I should have the IKE side I should have
had you sing like a theme song to it
with your
walking up and down New Orleans and
singing that [ __ ] that was I was so fun
it was the best yeah it was good
so you got your album come first album
second album session is called pop dog
suicide this one's called a legend a
quick fat I should've been I thought
about that it might be the third one
this one's called read the room comes
out April 26th April 26 yeah the order
for that okay
pre-order April 11th and then the oh
podcast about last night yeah the the
very funny Bear Williams and Adam Ray
about last night I've been on that a few
times I really enjoy Chuck with you guys
it's just I've never been on the video
version of it though yeah well that's
next yeah disco these guys well I might
I just looked at a place today that made
maybe move to is from up the upgrade in
the whole podcast situation we also are
gonna do a podcast cruise over a hallo
and that's crew yeah 20 20 Halloween
weekend what does that mean that's the
same people do Adam Carolla's podcast
cruises we're gonna do cruise about last
night cruise yeah why are you gonna
invite other podcast like where for what
Griffin can be there and maybe we gotta
find out how many tickets we're gonna
sell first we got 20 20 s will be fine
in examinees or is it gonna be a rowboat
like six tickets really okay yeah and
they're not that you can be then you
work we find your road dates and all
they come Adam right comedy calm is all
my tour dates and I'm pretty much I got
a you know through through the fall and
Miami improv this weekend act me in
Minnesota next week and Moontower Comedy
Festival in and I never get into that
they never invite me to that I'll talk
to Colleen you should be there for sure
you should take your podcast down there
next year yeah they just never yeah they
never paid and they kevin being able
foolishness show is April 26th all right
you know those guys know these people
man I may know Jim Carrey do you think I
know him yeah I don't know him if I saw
me be like hey Eric but it's not like I
have a number
got his number no dude nobody has his
number I'll be the first nail with it
done one time I tried to get his no I
tried to get in contact with him I'm
going to show that cancel just to be
like hey man let's say thank you yeah
nobody couldn't get it why they just
they said no he's a real person anymore
and he's not a real like these people
get so that's another thing when you
have dumb money and you are then you
have like attached enough money where
you have like a certain type of
lifestyle where you don't even go to
ATMs you don't know how to like send a
FedEx package these are these kind of
people he had to since I mean you've got
to assistant money like dude you know I
even grocery shopping you don't even
know what anything is and you imagine
being so detached like walking to the
grocery store after like 20 years of not
doing it and you sell the other ones
like vegetables this is where we get the
piece of [ __ ] yeah I only see them when
they're fully done and yeah yeah so I'm
just saying how do you pronounce this
Marie Callender Maria who is that some
famous chef Nick Heine when you're poor
you go to real good they're brought to
you by VMAs mom we'll listen I know you
gotta go that's like to do ten let's do
like eight more minutes okay eight look
you said it like I would love to do
another two hours I could talk to you
forever yeah I know this will be part
one you know I love that you have a lot
of part one hard times here Adam ray
part one well that's good I wouldn't
even or what do you want to know we go
on a tangent ah yeah that's great though
yeah I know
let's get back to the facts get back to
like so you were in Seattle holy show
you left Seattle what did you come here
first time you came to LA so I came here
to visit LA with my buddy and his dad to
do like a college search and my but I
didn't go to college he's a killing of a
musician in Seattle but we visited
Lowell Marymount San Diego the school's
UCLA USC and then um
Pepperdine and I love parrot I want a
beautiful campus unbelievable yeah and I
remember really meeting one of the guys
who like it showed people around because
it's a is that school is a heavily
Christian or Catholic
I think it's Catholic a Catholic school
so remember mentioning being making a
joke about being like obvi I'll be one
of your a few Jews here huh remember the
guy who was taking us around made a
weird face like a joke ever is I can't
say Jew without bastard racism you can't
even do that anymore I know dude um I
know dude
he's so [ __ ] funny um um used to but
I did his pockets on the Laugh Factory
Network we called my Aunt Shirley who's
90 and she just had a stroke and we
called her up and and I was like I'm
Shirley can you tell fishy at the time
she'd be married to my uncle for 65
years right and then he passed away and
she was like it living in this home and
she's like I've got uh sometimes
boyfriend now and I was like what's the
sometimes boyfriend she's like sometimes
we hold hands and gums like oh it's
[ __ ] adorable you know and then he
goes and then he goes and he kept
calling her Muriel and I was like I
named Shirley goes as same [ __ ] yeah
that goes in that game to a certain age
you become Muriel yeah and Tom Kersting
one point she goes quickly please not
swear I go surely you don't swear no
only when I'm by myself when I drop
something and Dom goes so you're like
what oh [ __ ] the pasta and I have to go
I can't talk anymore oh man yeah becomes
terrorized you're 90 year old I thought
that's in a home yeah you're a monster
so we visit old schools and then I came
back down in 2001 to go to your see I
you know applied for the the school like
you know I'm like you know the way
things are done now isn't that crazy
Becky Oh 13 I wonder if they gonna get
jail time altitude if I wonder if they
go into jail you're gonna go to like a
Martha Stewart Jail
can we just talk about this for a second
before you go yeah this is one I don't
understand you want your kid to go to
college right
for the prestige of that whatever it is
I guess right or do you want them what
what is the purpose of that I wanted to
go to college because I wanted to do
acting so I auditioned for the acting
school and I was like no but I'm saying
as a parent oh for sure
I'm saying as a parent you want the
experience I think you I think there are
for me especially my mom preached this
she was like cuz I you know I was like
oh I'll just go to University of
Washington stay close to home you know
because she still by herself and just
met my stepdads and the timing was right
but I was like she's like no you gotta
get away even if she was gonna be by
herself she's like you need to go away
for school and experience that you need
to be on your own
she's like you need to like grow up have
some time away from home and and learn
about and just like you got to grow like
that and then I think there are a lot of
benefits to that because you are like
nobody knows I'm parent though and not
have any sort of like safety net you
know what I'm saying as a parent like
first of all I think it's change must be
furious with my mom if she spent a
million five for me to go to college let
me do what we I mean look we gotta be
like [ __ ] my grandparents have to look
for its money oh for sure for sure I
just go to DeVry my grandparents helped
me for about two years I think it was 20
20 28 I think a semester when I went oh
God and which I think now it's close to
65 70 yeah so this was 2001 or 2002 five
so and then I got a couple grants I got
um financial aid you're gonna help you
hilarious
I know Jubilee I got to help us get the
grant that way I wanted to like pretend
I was a manager oh yeah Jerry Juhl
Bergen Steen I want to say bye call hi
I'm Jerry Joo Bergen Steen I'm calling
about Eric Griffin that is a great
manager agent voice so yeah so it's all
right financial aid and and and then I
got some you're paid scholarship wise
from grades and stuff
three four jobs that helped a lot to get
all that financial help but then I just
paid them off probably six years ago now
I know but I'm just saying I don't
understand why if it was that much
though and my mom was like this is what
we're gonna have to go through I would
probably would have taken a step back
and be like alright maybe I could just
take some theater classes here and then
move to LA LA and try to just immerse
myself in the biz know but I know but
here's the thing these people are rich
okay so their kids are like that one of
the kids is like a blogger making money
I'm just saying if it was for the
prestige if is to say okay well how can
you how can it be for the prestige if
you know you paid for it
does the prestige is just from you
nothing they care it's also because of
are the parents wanting their kids to go
to school and be away from them and not
have to like I love that kids around the
house or they're not living in a
two-bedroom condo in Reseda
so you got to know that kids not gonna
there must be something in delusional in
the parents mind like in Lori Loughlin
smile when she's like maybe if she goes
to school she'll actually make some [ __ ]
of herself and not be and and get
inspired of being around other
intellectual people I will not be stuck
in a room vlogging or posting new tapes
or whatever she I don't know what she's
doing to make money but okay but how
about this how about this growing up a
little how about this because my mom
that how about you tell your kid I'll
give you a million dollars if you get
into college Wow how about that Wow
yeah that's good parenting talk about
motivation many good parents even in my
agent for number one would have said
look I got $15,000 my mom used to say
I'll give you 20 bucks and you stop
biting your fingers use [ __ ] like you
know what's up with these fingernails is
there something I don't know
what are you doing woman you know look
at that that's amazing to the back to
the beginning
I just different ways to motivate yeah I
think I think you just motivate them
just say like imagine if you say I got a
million dollars in a trust fund it's
gonna go to charity
yeah or it can go to you if you get into
Yale that's what's truly tough about I
think kids now or at least just this
generation is like where do you get that
money
motivation is tough no matter how you
slice it us everyday you're like we're
trying to figure out have to motivate
myself every day even just like to do
this [ __ ] blast you don't want to go
through like you're doing all the the
trials and tribulations and the trial
and errors of just putting this together
yourself what you're going it's like but
even just to get you I mean like to the
amount of like jobs that I've not gotten
in the past five years and when I really
take a step back I think that's why you
keep yourself busy so you're not
spending time thinking about stuff but
what I really do sit down and think
about like and let myself go through
like all I remember remember that
audition member I almost got that number
that it's mind-blowing yeah overwhelming
almost every night and then and then you
gonna you know have to meet that with
like a pat on the back and go oh look
what I got to do I got to do dr. oz and
Charlotte you know and then uh but then
you but then you go god the amount of
things that like and then did I one of
your credits I got to Dieppe dr. oz I
like how you said it's gonna make like a
you said that like you're gonna be like
putting elbows back he gave me a kale
salad tip no but like going through
anything that you you know of the
rejection and then finding a way to then
to just do it all over again
yeah and put yourself back in front of
what else yeah this is weird business
cuz this is all no yeah I literally was
just talking to you know what I guess an
occasional yes yeah and a lot of no yeah
I just was talking to somebody who was
like oh you're a comic I know jack how
rough life I was like alright so this is
who do they know yeah it was they're
basing this off of you know and then I
always go to defense mode rum like me a
can view it now it's great you know I'm
regular all the clothes a boy in Miami
this week and you know five six hours
you know read I not first class it's
great you know and I do try to find the
things that I do love about it and also
try to be like hey like put in the work
still putting in the work it's a con you
don't ever just get to a point and it's
great but I go all right from her
perception for sure like she's probably
and then she told me she's a big fan of
crashing and so she's like she's like
that just seems like it depicts it just
to be so tough how do you do any how do
you have fun at you yeah I'm like I mean
you do like obviously this is why
not doing it I always feel like my
career is like I'm on a treadmill but
it's set to one so I don't know if I'm
progressing at all I have to go a long
time then I have to look back and be
like oh [ __ ] I've actually done some
things you know Wow you know I guess
will my career's like being on a stair
step there I'm stair stepper I'm
constantly climbing and hoping I can get
off soon are you constantly watching The
Today Show yeah I know but that's but I
don't know what is our motivation why do
we keep doing it I guess it's just the
need to just keep saying things and
doing things and being seen yeah
performing if you don't have the love
for that and all the stuff that goes
with it and this isn't for you yeah I'm
also so glad I'm in LA I love everything
every day I Drive around here and just
like this place rules you mention leave
it anywhere else I know I'm you know I
can I do want to live other places yeah
Alex I like Seattle Pacific Northwest
crush Seattle you could probably kinking
a comma in Seattle they River on the
road why would you want to be there if
you're if you're the king anywhere yeah
then you're done whoa is that it you put
LeBron on blast Oh God isn't he I mean
that's a whole other podcast steps down
yeah if Magic Johnson is like here I
can't not even I can [ __ ] I know how
to spell that's gonna turn this [ __ ]
around 30 years with HIV but nine months
with LeBron and he's I mean how do you
not drugged him like a ninja
[Music]
spell cast spell out load anyways that's
been another fantastic episode of
riffing with Griffing I think it was
fantastic was you just actually didn't
you're gonna end up being my actual
first official guest I love that you
know we would Jesse may that's gonna be
the lost episode the technical
difficulties episode but I think this is
the episode where I got it right and we
did it this is Adam ray it's got his
album coming out with the name of the
album read the room drops Abel 26 the
room drops April 26 you can do it with
Adam Raycom for my comedy calm
Adam rate comedy calm and you know
obviously I met Erik Griffin calm and
you know thanks for listening a riffing
with Griffin and we will I'll see you
next week I might be by myself or I
might have somebody sitting there I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm doing all
this is gonna change as it go I'm
growing people stop stop stop judging
yes the judgment you know just know it's
happening really people can't stay when
the pictures are like you know are there
the glove that they were obsessed about
like that no I've to see people I don't
know me I've been yeah I've been
blogging about you oh this [ __ ]
you I love this picture by the way shows
you how big NBA players and I do like
you're super tall yeah dude it's Chris
Paul looks little like on TV but look at
he's bigger than me I'm six-three but
anyways that's it we're for what Griffin
thanks guys see you
[Music]